Trump continues to dominate in the polls
and he's getting stronger and stronger
in the polls I am the chosen
well right now out of Quinnipiac that
shows Trump not only beating the rest of
the GOP field by law which he's doing
but Trump beating Biden and and not just
Trump beating Biden at the national
level Trump beating Biden in
Pennsylvania Pennsylvania is supposed to
be Joe Biden's home turf good old
Scranton Joe and Trump is beating him
there 47-46 so it's close but Trump is
still ahead there so the argument that
Trump can't win is falling apart so now
one of the big anti-trump lines in the
primary is gone it's gone on the idea
that he can't win and it's gone on the
idea that well the national polls don't
matter yeah maybe the national polls
don't tell you everything but the state
polls do and even in the contentious
Battleground State polls Trump's looking
pretty good